habe einen Mann bei uns Klassen
langjährigen Energiemanager in
Deutschland der gerade bitterbös die
deutsche Situationen energiepolitisch
hier analysiert hat und gesagt hat unser
Land ist
dysfunktional wird das Funktionieren ihm
gegenüber sitzt ein Mann er versteht
Gründer von LichtBlick der einen Roman
gerade geschrieben hat ein Krimi ein
Thriller der den jetzt auch nicht
wahnsinnig positiven Titel trägt die
Welt kippt was gibt da eigentlich gerade
ja die Welt gibt ja an verschiedenen
Stellen im Moment in meinem Buch geht es
auch ums Klima und um die Frage ob
unsere westlichen Demokratien das was
wir hier jetzt auch gerade diskutieren
eigentlich mit ihrer
langsamen Art und Weise Dinge überhaupt
auf dem Weg zu bringen in der Lage sind
ein so langfristig wirkendes Problem wie
die Klimakatastrophe
bewältigen zu können was geht ihnen zu
langsam geht ihm zu langsam der
Entschluss die Atomkraftwerke länger
laufen zu lassen das ist aber
Beispiel von vielen ich will hier gar
nicht inhaltlich werden sondern die
Politik ist und es gar kein deutsches
Phänomen übrigens Demokratien sind
heutzutage aufgrund der Tatsache dass
sie versuchen alle möglichen
Partikularinteressen zu berücksichtigen
bestmöglich zu berücksichtigen im Grunde
genommen ganz stark handlungsunfähig
geworden ja und ich will damit nicht
sagen dass ich ein Freund der Diktatur
bin ganz bestimmt natürlich nicht obwohl
in meinem Roman China dann eine ganz
andere Rolle spielt aber man muss den
Finger in die Wunde legen ja und man
muss gemeinsam doch darüber diskutieren
mit den Politikern auch als Bürger
untereinander was können wir eigentlich
tun damit unser demokratisches System
das natürlich fraglos das Beste ist was
wir so langsam aber
neulich bei den Tonka direkt im
Finanzministerium vorbei geschaut haben
da plötzlich mit der Besuchergruppe rein
sind und ja direkt neben so von ihrem
Finanzminister und neben ihrem standen
plötzlich auf dem Balkon waren ihre
transparente dort ausgerollt haben sie
stellen die Frage her von wie weit darf
man eigentlich gehen wenn man die Welt
retten möchte das heißt diese Leute
gehen die ihnen zu weit oder nicht ich
glaube das ist nicht eine Frage des zu
weit oder nicht ziviler Ungehorsam ist
finde ich etwas Ministerium einbrechen
hätte ich jetzt überhaupt kein Problem
zu sagen das geht mir soweit ja ich
finde sie wieder Ungehorsam so lange das
gewaltfrei bleibt ja ist was was mit
Demokratie aushalten muss das Problem
ist hier was ganz anderes die Frage ist
doch ob mit den Aktionen die hier gerade
stattfinden die Masse mitgenommen wird
er wird eigentlich die Masse mitgenommen
um wirklich eine Revolution die wir
brauchen in der Energiewirtschaft
anzustoßen Fragezeichen
darauf das andere in ihrem Alltag
behindert werden und wenn wir das alle
machen das ist ja immer die schöne Frage
Manuel kann was wenn wir das alle machen
wenn wir alle bei unserer Meinung oder
dem was uns wichtig ist so agieren dann
geht das immer nur auf Kosten alle
anderen Menschen so kann der
Gesellschaft nicht funktionieren
deswegen bin ich in der Tat der Meinung
wir müssen die Versammlungen haben wir
müssen Demonstrationen haben wir müssen
Meinungsäußerung haben aber keine
militantenaktionen wie die die da
stattfinden das heißt die schütteln den
Kopf an der Stelle
sitzen hier und das darf ich einmal
sagen haben gleichzeitig Wohnsitz das
heißt wenn hier der Strom weg ist dann
können Sie immer noch in Großbritannien
den Strom empfangen ich ich schüttele
deshalb den Kopf weil die Vorschläge die
meinen Kollege hier macht sind ja genau
die die in der Demokratie nicht
funktioniert weil sie einfach viel zu
langsam
sind das funktioniert nicht das hat darf
ich mehr dann in der Tat werden Regeln
zerstört und ich glaube nicht dass das
funktioniert ansonsten würde ich aber
sehr davor warnen jetzt auch irgendwie
die Diktatur und zu rot zu sehen
corona-politik gemacht hat übrigens mit
beträchtigen wirtschaftlichen Schaden
unintelligible handeln auch nicht immer
rational wir haben ja auch eine Diktatur
Erfahrung an diesem Tisch aber noch
einmal zur zu Ihnen und zu ihrer
persönlichen Lage sie sind für die
schnelleren für den schnelleren Wandel
auf dem Energiemarkt für schnellere
Anwendung zu Ökostrom sie haben auch
eine gewisse Sympathie habe ich gerade
rausgehört für diejenigen die bei ein
Tonka da im Finanzministerium
eingebrochen sind machen sie sich aber
wenn der Strom hier ausfällt aus dem
Staub und nehme mir einen Zweitwohnsitz
das mache ich natürlich nicht aber es
geht ja gar nicht darum wofür ich bin
sondern dass wir schneller handeln
müssen das ist ja Konsens ich meine das
was im Moment auf der ganzen Welt
passiert ist nicht schnell genug ja das
ist fraglos inzwischen so da bin ich ja
glücklich ja die Diskussion gibt's den
Klimawandel überhaupt und können wir uns
nicht noch 20 Jahre Zeit lassen die sind
ja verschwunden die Frage wohin handeln
und richtig haben will und nicht richtig
richtig
aber wir haben keinen Strom Problem und
das hat nichts mit den Strompreis
rationale Denken ja es gibt keinen
Politikbereich der so sehr sachlicher
logischer Entscheidungsfindung
zugänglich wäre wie die Energiepolitik
weil das ja alles letztlich Physik ist
und es gibt keinen Bereich in dem seit
20 30 Jahren die Rationalität jeden Tag
so sehr mit Füßen getrieben wird und
wenn wir nur das überwinden könnten wenn
wir mal pragmatisch mit dem gesunden
Menschenverstand auch in der
Energiepolitik Entscheidung treffen
könnten dann könnten wir gleichzeitig
das Richtige und auch noch Züge tun also
weniger Träumen sagen sie will noch
einmal ganz konkret die Frage wissen die
für Sie als nächstes ganz entscheidend
ist bei der sie eine rationale und keine
träumerische oder ihnen ideologische
Antwort erwarten ich möchte nicht mehr
hören dass wir gleichzeitig Klima aus
Klimaschutz und Kernenergie Ausstieg in
vollem Umfang betreiben können ich
möchte nicht mehr hören das Wärme und
Strom und russisches Gas und Preise
nichts miteinander zu tun haben und wenn
wir überhaupt mal anfangen uns von
diesen Widersprüchen zu abschieben und
einfach physikalisch unmittelbare
Widersprüche nicht mehr zu behaupten nur
weil sie in die Ideologie passen dann
können wir ab morgen eine bessere und
sinnvollere Energiepolitik
ich stimme überein dass wir uns werden
entscheiden müssen wie wir die
Klimaziele erreichen wollen und das kann
man mit Kohle und auch mit krass nie
machen und insofern braucht man neben
den Erneuerbaren auf absehbare Zeit
komplementär was anderes und da wird
sich diese Gesellschaft mit beschäftigen
müssen wenn sie sich diesen Klimazielen
verpflichtet fühlt ich finde das sollte
sie tun wenn Herr Klassen das so
eindringlich sagt und sie im im
weitesten Recht geben haben sie trotzdem
hinter im Hinterkopf wir regieren ja
gerade in das heißt doch nicht das heißt
doch nicht dass man aufhört selbst zu
denken es war ja auch die FDP die die
Laufzeiten verlängert hat wir haben
übrigens auch durchgesetzt dass die
europäischen Autos auch künftig noch mit
klimaneutralen Kraftstoffen gefahren
werden sollen dürfen damit das nicht nur
mit Strom passieren soll
gerade gesprochen im Kernkraft Problem
bleiben da sagen sie erstmal dann wäre
dafür gesorgt dass das
gelöst ist erstmal über den Winter und
so weiter das Problem kommt wieder auf
dem Tisch haben sie schon Brennelemente
bestellt oder wann müssen Sie die
bestellen wir haben natürlich noch keine
Brennelemente bestellt weil sie genau
wissen dass wir bis zum 16 April die
Laufzeiten jetzt vereinbart haben genau
das ist aber jetzt über den Winter
hinweg die ähm auch der Januar der
Februar der März werden diese Kraftwerke
weiter zur Verfügung stehen und dann am
16 ist wir werden uns noch mal anschauen
wieder Winter gelaufen
sie wissen genau dass ich auch zu
längeren Laufzeiten gewesen wäre das ist
klar man kann anderer Meinung sein ich
will aber von Herrn Tonka wissen wann er
damit anfängt der wird nicht warten bis
zum 16 der hat seinen Plan schon in der
Tasche
das wirklich nicht sie lassen sich
zukommen wir haben jetzt eine Regelung
getroffen die war die war politisch
nicht leicht zu erreichen aber sie hilft
unintelligible abgewischt und da das
nächste wie geht's weiter wann knallen
sie das den Grünen wieder von den Leuten
wir knallt den Grünen gar nichts vor dem
Latz sondern wir schauen uns an wie sich
jetzt die Stromversorgung vom Anschauen
wird sich nicht ändern vor 15 Jahren
gesagt wir dürfen wir müssen in eine
globale solare Energiewirtschaft da gibt
es gar keinen Zweifel ja wir dürfen es
aber nicht tun indem wir temporär
fossile Energien zementieren wie spielt
Steinkohle oder jetzt russisches Gas wir
müssen es tun indem wir Energieeffizienz
erhöhen und indem wir in der Lage sind
die Sonnenenergie aus den Regionen wo
sie anfällt Sahara Mojave Wüste Kalahari
dahin zu bringen wo sie gebraucht wird
und in den 15 Jahren ist nichts getan um
dafür die nicht die die die die die
grenzübergreifenden Netzstrukturen zu
schaffen das hätte man alles tun können
und damit müssen wir im Grunde morgen
beginnen das heißt wir müssen zwei
gleich arbeiten wir müssen über den
Winter kommen in einer
sozialverträglichen Form und das ist
Aufgabe nicht nur der Energiepolitik
sondern der sozial und für skalpolitik
und wir müssen in der Energiepolitik
morgen anfangen wirklich logisch
vernünftig aus dem was wir wollen die
entsprechenden Maßnahmen herzuleiten
den Kopf geschildert und tief geatmet
immer wieder warum ja also erstmal
müssen wir aus dieser komischen
Scheindebatte raus Atomkraft ist fertig
in Deutschland Punkt aus und wer das
nicht akzeptiert der der verkennt der
Realitäten es wird keine Atomkraft bei
uns mehr geben die Leute wollen das
nicht wir sind selbst die Bevölkerung
die meint der Großteil der Bevölkerung
ist gegen gerade was ganz anderes es gab
diese Jahre als der Atomausstieg nämlich
beschlossen wurde da war die Stimmung
genauso wie sie geschildert haben
zumindest Umfrage vorgesetzt wir hätten
eine Stromlücke und dafür wollen sie
dafür noch die Atomkraft haben die Leute
ja für die stromlöcke wenn sie denn da
ist aber die Stromlücke die wir
tatsächlich haben wenn wir sie denn
haben ich glaube auch nicht an
irgendwelche Frauen aus oder Blackouts
die kommen glaube ich nicht weil ich
unterhalte mich ja auch mit den
Energieversorgern keine Ahnung wollen
Kohlekraft diese Problematik mit der
Atomkraft ist doch die wir brauchen
gerade so viel Strom weil Frankreich so
viel Atomkraftwerke hat und die laufen
nicht die laufen nicht weil es bei uns
immer zu trocken und zu heiß wird und
dann diese Dinger nicht mehr gekühlt
werden können französische Atomkraft hat
bisher die deutschen Strompreise runter
gehalten
ist hier wieder das Hauptproblem noch
die Lösung dass der entscheidende Punkt
ist dass wir im Bereich des Ausbaus der
erneuerbaren Energien Dinge gemacht
haben die zum Teil ineffizient waren die
zum Teil
Spekulationsgewinne erzeugt haben
Privatisierung von Gewinnen
Sozialisierung von Verlusten und dass
wir im Bereich der globalen solaren
Strukturen von denen wir profitieren
könnten grenzübergreifen nichts getan
haben also wenn man konkreten eine
eigene Industrie aufbauen können hier
wunderbar Sonne empfangen war alles in
effizien
gehen Sie mal nach Hannover und schauen
Sie sich das Wetter haben dann verstehen
Sie den Unterschied aber lassen wir
danken lassen Sie mich das bitte noch
einmal unterstreichen was vorbei und
unter Klassen gerade gesagt haben die
Atomenergie Diskussion ist völlig
sinnlos sie ist völlig sinnlos wir
können über eine Verlängerung sprechen
das ist mir egal ja weil wir Ideologie
frei diskutieren müssen das löst aber
überhaupt kein Problem ja wenn wir neue
wenn wir neue Atomkraftwerke bauen
würden ja wäre das ein Weg den man
diskutieren könnte aber das findet nicht
statt das wird auch nie stattfinden
relativ lange es dauert nicht relativ
lange es dauert 20 Jahre ja bis sie
neues Atomkraftwerk am Netz haben und
bis dahin sind die erneuerbar und so
weiter würde noch viel länger dauern
zweitens ist Atomkraft die teuerste
Energie die man sich vorstellen kann
teurer als erneuerbare sowieso teurer
als Kohle und sogar teurer als Gast aber
sicher sauber ganz bestimmt nicht sicher
aber das ist wieder eine persönliche
Meinung aber sicherlich
wenn Sie die Kosten einer Solaranlage
und eines Windrads inklusive Speicher
Backup um zuverlässig über das ganze
Jahr den Strom zur Versorgung zur
Verfügung stellen zu können die Kosten
vergleichen mit einem Atomkraftwerk ist
das Atomkraftwerk mehr als doppelt so
teuer ein neu gebautes deshalb ist die
Diskussion völlig sinnlos die muss nicht
mehr geführt werden
es geht also ich glaube auch nicht dass
in Deutschland momentan eine Diskussion
geführt wird über den groß angelegten
Wiedereinstieg sondern die Diskussion
dreht sich um die Frage ob man in einer
Energiekrise die noch nicht komplett
unter Kontrolle ist alle technologischen
Optionen nutzt oder sich zumindest
aufrecht erhält oder nicht und ich
befürchte und ich bedauere sehe dass
offensichtlich die Antwort jetzt auf der
kurze mittleren Sicht in Deutschland
mehr Kohle heißt denn wir dürfen ja
nicht immer nur die Schwächen jeder
Energie thematisieren wir müssen ja auch
sehen dass wir mit der Entscheidung
gegen die eine eine Entscheidung für
eine andere Technologie treffen und das
ist in dem Fall die fossile Kohle und
wenn wir all das Hören der Klassen ist
ihr Eindruck ihr Wissen dass in den
nächsten Jahren auch so wie wir mit die
Politik erleben unser Stromproblem in
Deutschland kleiner wird oder eher
größer wird es wird größer wenn wir
nicht von der Ideologisierung wegkommen
erlauben Sie mir zwei Sätze zu kennen
Energie ich selbst habe vor 15 Jahren
vorgeschlagen als Chef eines großen
Energiekonzerns den Kernenergie Ausstieg
in der Verfassung fest zu schreiben ich
bin kein kernenergie-lobbyist oder
Fetisch ist aber wenn wir sagen der
Klimawandel ist das größte Problem was
die Menschheit hat dann ist jede Tonne
und jedes Gramm vermieden des CO2
wichtig und dann ist jeder Monat in ein
Kernkraftwerk Leiter laufen kann wichtig
und wenn wir sagen das soziale Problem
der Strompreise im Winter kann vital
werden dann ist auch da jede Kosten
seitige Entlastung die wir haben können
wichtig und weil die bestehenden Kraft
merke ja im Grunde abgeschrieben sind
ist natürlich das auch ein Entlastendes
Element um nicht die preissteigernden
Effekte des ausbleibenden russischen
Gases zu sozialunverträglich werden zu
lassen unser Stromproblem wird erstmal
offenbar nicht kleiner sondern größer
freien Käfer rechnen Sie damit dass die
Preise auch weiter steigen oder
zumindest auf absehbare Sicht nicht
sinken werden wir in der Politik so
weitermachen ist wird das wahrscheinlich
der Fall sein wenn wir uns gegenseitig
zerstreiten und immer nur über
Allgemeinheiten reden über Erwägungen
ich frage mich ganz konkret wann kommt
die übergewinnsteuer die sicherstellt
dass wir hier keine sinnvoll
Profession
eingesetzt wird wir brauchen die
zeitenwände auch auf dem Energiemarkt
und das war muss diese zeitenwände
sozialverträglich sein
dazu brauchen wir die übergewinnsteuer
dazu brauchen wir das Geld
beim Fehler hier so etwas überhaupt
zuzulassen in dieser Woche eine Erlös
Abschöpfung heißt das wo sehr sehr hohe
Margen von einzelnen Stromerzeugern
abgeschöpft werden ob er nicht in den
zum Finanzminister gehen wie eine Steuer
sondern direkt im Strommarkt bleiben bei
den Netzbetreibern und dann in
niedrigere Strompreise umgesetzt werden
also das ist genau
Verteilungskampf auch auf dem
Energiemarkt und dann müssen wir die
soziale Seite sehen
ihre Kunden Verbraucherzentrale Fragen
ja ist es jetzt nur vorübergehend vorbei
dort oder wird es so bleiben was sagen
sie denn also die Preise waren bisschen
wieder runtergehen sie werden nicht auf
das vor ich will nicht sagen vor kriegst
Niveau sondern auf das
2020er Niveau zurückgehen definitiv
nicht sie werden weiter oben bleiben und
ich hoffe einfach mal dass wir von
diesem ganzen komischen bremsen und den
ganzen Kram Weg kommt der jetzt hier auf
die Schnelle irgendwie geschossen wird
dass das Finanzministerium zum Beispiel
endlich mal die Voraussetzung schafft
dass wir tatsächlich gezielter Gelder
den Leuten zukommen lassen können dies
brauchen dann können wir uns dieses
ganze traras Spanien mit diesen
Abrechnungen mit diesen ganzen
Rattenschwanz da hinten dran hängt und
ich möchte natürlich auch dass wir haben
jetzt ganz viele Wärmepumpen gefördert
und eingebaut und wenn sie die mit 40
Cent pro Kilowattstunde sozusagen
betreiben sollen das geht nicht da muss
auch noch was kommen irgendwie das Wort
bei uns in der Runde der Lichtblick
gegründet hat und den Blick auch in
seinem Roman in die Zukunft wirft was
ist der Strompreis bei dem sie glücklich
sind sie haben zu Beginn der Sendung
gesagt ich bin eigentlich ganz happy das
Strom fertiger geworden ist auch teurer
geworden ist weil wegen Strompreis sind
sie happy und wo endet die Reise es im
Moment zu hoch gar keine Frage er war in
der Vergangenheit zu niedrig also
irgendwo dazwischen
wäre mir am liebsten weil dann die Leute
und auch die auch das Gewerbe und auch
die Industrie
behutsam damit umgehen werden und da
kommen wir auch hin also Strom ist ja
ein börsenprodukt sie können heute schon
sehen was der Strom in zwei drei vier
fünf sechs Jahren kostet und wir sind im
Moment in dem Peak und das geht wieder
stark nach unten und wenn wir 100%
erneuerbar sind wird der Strom ganz
billig ja im Moment sind wir in Bayern
paar kleinen Prozentchen ein ganz weiter
weg diese Sendung hat mich immer nur Mut
gemacht muss ganz ehrlich zugeben das
letzte Wort aber der Strompreis wird
wieder etwas sinken